Before we begin our class, we are going
to take a look at our Blueprint.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
Now, first things first, Blueprint
has a flow direction or a flow control.
And this goes from left to right,
just like you read in English.
So if we start right here, our flow will always
or execution will always go from here this way.
And we will continue like that throughout our graph.
Now, there are a few ways that we can control this flow.
The most simplistic ways is going to be
our branch or our if statement, which is right up here.
This works with a condition.
We have something that comes in here.
And then based off this condition,
we're going to have a true or a false.
So if something comes in here, if it's true,
it's going to fire off the execution off of the true.
If it's not true, it can fire the execution off of the false.
We can also have this condition
set to a variable, which will allow us to base
the execution of this action off of other input
in other areas of the project.
Next, we have a flip-flop.
Flip-flops are really cool because of how they work.
They will always do one input and then the other.
So when we get an input into a flip-flop,
we can always be assured that it will fire A and then B
and keep repeating this pattern.
These are really good if you would like to maybe do something
on button click, and then when you click it again,
it reverses that behavior or some other type of behavior
that you know is going to have one output and then
another output.
Now, sequence nodes are useful in that they allow you
to fire off execution to a bunch of different parts
of your code all at one time.
Now, you can add additional VIN pins in your sequence
by pressing the Add Pin button right here.
And again, this will fire off a bunch of different executions.
It will do them in order that they
come inside of the sequence.
So it will go then 0s, then 1, but there
is no delay in the execution.
They will always fire from the top
and then go down to the bottom and fire off instantaneously.
Next, we have the switch on int.
So switch on int allows us to provide an integer or an input
and then make a change based off of that.
Switching on integer is a lot more useful
than having to constantly remember
the variable name or some other complicated name.
And simply having a number like 1, 2, 3, or 4
be able to change the output is super, super useful.
Last but not least, we have a gate.
And a gate is used for executional-based conditional
checking.
So if we are trying to check for some type of condition,
while we are executing a piece of code,
we could use a gate to set up the structure for that.
Now, we're not done just yet because Blueprints also
have a way to control time.
Now, you might be thinking, well, I
could just make a timer.
If I have full execution control,
I could probably get the game time.
And yes, you could do that, but there
are some built-in things that work way better.
So first off, I want to talk about delays
and retriggerable delays.
Now, delays are a great little piece of code
if you want to wait for a specific amount of time.
In fact, if you put a delay of 0, 0,
that will act as a single-frame delay
inside of Blueprints.
And this is actually utilized in Fortnite as well as
Robo Recall.
Inside the Robo Recall Mall, they actually
will pause stuff on a single frame to do calculations.
And again, if you take a delay node
and you put that duration to 0, 0,
it's that one-frame delay that's
often needed to help things spawn in without twitching.
Now, there's also a retriggerable delay,
which will retrigger after a duration.
Now, the problem with these delays
are these are kind of fire and forget nodes.
Once we fire these off, we have no control over them.
We just kind of have to wait for them.
So we set it, and we kind of wait for it to do its thing.
And while that's good for many, many things,
oftentimes that's not really good when we want precision.
If we want precision, this is where
the set timer by event and set timer by function name nodes
come in real handy.
With these two nodes, we can set them
to listen for a specific event or a specific function
and use this to help define how we keep track of time.
One of the things to note on both of these nodes
is both the time and the looping option.
This allows us to basically create a timer of any duration,
whether it's 0.1 seconds or 500 seconds.
And we can even have that repeat some behavior
on looping.
So every time it counts maybe down for one second,
we could have it loop and come back.
So this is really going to work in our advantage
as it's going to take a lot of the hard work of getting
our game time, converting that game time into a real time
that we could actually utilize to do things
like keep track of our time.
Super, super simple and makes everything
much more approachable.
Now, the last node that we're going to talk about here
is a timeline.
Now, a timeline is how you can animate objects inside
of Blueprints.
Timelines will be added to the Blueprint graph,
and they allow us to animate objects or properties of objects
going from point A to point B in a linear fashion.
While we aren't using timelines necessarily
in this particular project, they
are super useful to know about.
All right, this will finish up our Blueprints quick review
We'll now move on to Unreal Motion
Graphics in our next video.